[Music]
so here i have two devices
and i will transfer one dollar from this
device to this device
instantaneously
enter the amount
and send
i'm singing the transaction now
and there it is
what you've just witnessed is what looks
like a standard financial transaction
money was transferred electronically
from one account to another
but while it appears like an ordinary
bank transfer
it may perhaps be the most revolutionary
technology
you're likely to see in your lifetime
this technology is called bitcoin
money makes possible the exchange of
many different
goods and services among many different
people
wherever we go we see money being used
as a medium of exchange
money is at the core of our existence
every day we transact with one another
currently almost all of our daily
transactions
involve a third party a bank
credit card company or remittance
provider
and ultimately it's these institutions
that carry out the transaction
on our behalf this is
until the invention of bitcoin
bitcoin is truly one of the most
important inventions
ever in the history of humankind that's
how big of an impact it's going to have
on our lives
and it sounds really difficult and
complicated and hard to understand
hearing about it
if you'd only heard about email it would
sound difficult and complicated and hard
use
bitcoin is literally easier to use than
email
so what exactly is bitcoin
well for starters bitcoin isn't
actually a coin bitcoin
is a new form of money a currency that
lives solely on the internet
one that some have even called magic
internet money
[Music]
i think part of the confusion is that
bitcoin is actually two different things
it's both a currency and a payment
network
and we've never had one thing that's
both of those at the same time so the
dollar is a currency
but it's not a payment network paypal
and visa are payment networks
but they're not currencies bitcoin is
both of those things at the same time
but it has this other property and that
other property is that it can instantly
be teleported
anywhere in the world just like that
almost for free
and there's nothing that anybody can do
to block these teleportations
there's nothing anybody can do to
intercept these teleportations and if
you're careful about how you use bitcoin
you can do these teleportations
anonymously so
with bitcoin with a push of a button you
can pay anyone anywhere in the world
or receive payment from anyone anywhere
in the world
[Music]
in the aftermath of the global financial
crisis
an author using the pseudonym satoshi
nakamoto
posted a nine-page document onto an
online forum
the document titled bitcoin a
peer-to-peer electronic
cash system would soon become the
building block for what is today
the first fully working concept of
decentralized money
these are the daily candles of bitcoin
just in the backdrop
but i want to talk about these are trend
lines you've seen them on other
presentations even earlier today
i started out working at bear stearns
back in 2007 so about a year and a half
or so before the financial crisis really
started to hit
and after bear stearns i joined j.p
morgan where i became a vp
and that was my last job all of these
jobs were either midtown or downtown
manhattan
tone vase is a wall street veteran
a former vp at jp morgan he now spends
his time
studying and educating audiences about
bitcoin bitcoin
is generally difficult to explain uh
you want to try and break it down as
simple as you can so the
simplest way is is basically it's a it's
like a message it's a digital message
that you're passing
and normally we're all used to computers
we're all sending emails we're all
sending pictures
but you're always sending a copy anytime
you hit the send button in a computer
you always retain a copy you always
retain the original
and when it comes to financial
transactions you hit the send button
and you have an intermediary the bank
that is moving money from one account to
another
and this is the problem that bitcoin
solved it was able to
take something digital and when you hit
the send button
you're not actually sending a copy
you're actually
sending um a digital object
at its core bitcoin is basically a new
monetary system
however bitcoin is unlike any other
system
we've seen in the past because it isn't
centralized
in one place this decentralized
nature of the bitcoin platform is one of
the things that make it so
unique and world-changing
[Music]
we're all familiar with paypal or visa
or bank of whatever
all of these traditional services that
we're used to
control who's allowed to have an account
who can send money from who
from what countries users can send money
to other countries users
with bitcoin there is no entity that's
controlling any of that there's just
this software protocol
that anyone can write software to
interact with and then anyone can
install that software on their phone or
on their computer
and once they have the software
installed they can now interact with
anyone else anywhere in the entire world
that's also using the bitcoin software
this software that runs the bitcoin
protocol
is commonly called a wallet a digital
purse
which stores and allows the holder to
move bitcoins from one wallet to
another the bitcoin protocol
is open source meaning that the
programming code
is freely available to add to and
redistribute
in this way similar to anyone being able
to add a new website to the world wide
web
programmers are able to add new products
to the bitcoin network
[Music]
we have jason for whom this is very late
evening because he's in australia
uh and we're about to do jason's first
bitcoin transaction
over skype as our medium so everyone can
see how quick and easy it is
on my end i will hit a send
and i jason is going to hit request
so when he hits request a qr code should
have displayed in the middle of your
screen
and he's going to put it up to the
camera of skype so i can scan it
with the camera in my cell phone all
right i see the qr code
my phone is trying to scan it and there
it is
i scanned it so i feel kind of generous
let's send jason
five dollars so i have just sent
jason five dollars in bitcoin
uh and let me know when it's registering
on your end
that you have five dollars worth of
bitcoin
and there it is okay so that took about
10 to 15 seconds
[Music]
bitcoin enables users to send and
receive money
instantly without the involvement of a
third party
this digital breakthrough allows the
user to effectively become their own
bank
this is a complex idea to handle but the
possibilities of this
new bankless currency are enormous
with the exception of actually handing
physical cash to you
generally we have to rely on third
parties for lots of different payments
be it credit cards or wire transfers
internationally
or even sort of keeping cash under your
bed storing large amounts of cash we use
banks
and what bitcoin does is allow us to do
all of those things without
any third parties so in that sense we
can be our own bank we can be our own
payment system
we can be our own international wire
system we can be our own remittance
system we can do all of these things
without relying on any other third
parties
that's what bitcoin allows us to do
[Music]
before bitcoin all these companies like
paypal and decent bank of america and
you know any business they had a ledger
that kept track of all their account
balances so paypal has a ledger that
keeps track of exactly who has how much
money in each paypal account
and that ledger is stored on paypal
servers and paypal's data center
somewhere
and before the invention of bitcoin
people thought that it was impossible
all the
mathematicians and computer scientists
thought that it was impossible
to have consensus on a distributed
ledger like this but what bitcoin did
is it came along and figured out how to
keep track of this ledger that keeps
track of who has what bitcoins but
instead of that ledger being on one data
center
it's on everybody's computer across the
entire planet that's running the bitcoin
network including my laptop right here i
have a full copy
of the entire bitcoin uh ledger
[Music]
this public ledger known as the
blockchain
is perhaps what could make bitcoin a
financial game changer
bitcoin is what is known as a
cryptocurrency
meaning that it's a digital currency in
which encryption is used
to regulate the creation of new units
and verify the transfer of funds
new bitcoins come into existence through
a process
called mining a miner is a person or
entity
who runs a very powerful computer in an
effort to solve a complex mathematical
puzzle
known as a block miners around the world
compete to solve or close a block and
are rewarded with newly generated
bitcoins
if they're successful all transactions
that travel through the bitcoin network
are pieces of this complex mathematical
puzzle
so when a miner solves a puzzle they're
actually verifying the integrity of each
and every transaction
welcome
this is one giant abandoned
recycling plant we've got incinerators
over there those two big silos
right around this wall we have a
mega watt worth of solar panels
it's a lot um that's
about as much as what we consume so
we're going to be able to offset
our electrical costs completely
this is a work in progress but
a bitcoin mine is a group of computers
that contribute its processing power to
facilitating bitcoin transfers
and the security of the network yeah it
is one big supercomputer
and all these individual computers are
kind of
throwing guesses at this mathematical
problem
it's a it's a very difficult problem it
takes lots and lots of computers
to guess it once that guess is
correct that is sent to all the rest of
the computers
and with that answer they record all the
transactions that have been
done up to that point it's a very secure
system for
uh facilitating transfers recording
transfers and making sure that
no kind of shady work has been done
because
there's some methods in in financial
transactions where you could double
spend
and this whole blockchain thing is one
great method of
making sure that doesn't happen
let's say if alice wants to send bob an
email
what would happen under the hood is that
along the path of the email across the
network
her email gets copied in many places of
the network
and eventually the final copy will be
relayed to bob
that's how email works that's how
digital transfers work and that's how it
should work for for the majority of
digital transfers
that's that's well and good however in
the case of money that would be
disastrous if
if that were to be the way that money
was transferred digitally
you don't want copies of the same dollar
bill
to be to exist on the network that that
would ruin the scarcity
uh uh premise of money
and so this was the problem that satoshi
nakamoto tackled with the the creation
of bitcoin
um and so what happens with bitcoin on
the bitcoins blockchain
is that when alice wants to send one
bitcoin to bob
she creates a transaction and that
transaction gets copied across the
entire network
however this is different than say a
single email because that transaction
has embedded in it instructions to the
rest of the network that says from here
on out
control over this bitcoin is now
conferred to bob
okay and the rest of the network honors
that
one time i i realized that wow bitcoin
is really difficult
for people to understand is i spent the
whole evening explaining bitcoin to a
friend of mine
and then i got home that night and uh
she posted on my facebook page and she
goes yeah i was thinking more about
bitcoins and you were explaining bitcoin
mining and
does that mean that bitcoins are
originally underground
i realized that bitcoin's a difficult
concept for for people to understand and
especially bitcoin mining as well
because bitcoins are not originally
underground
[Music]
for new users bitcoin can be a difficult
concept to understand
bitcoins aren't physical and they
certainly aren't underground
however there are some interesting
similarities between bitcoin and a
precious metal that is found underground
gold gold has been money and a store of
value
for thousands of years today
gold is mined all over the world
the amount of gold that can be extracted
from the ground
decreases over the life of a mine until
eventually
the miners exhausted of all of its gold
bitcoins are also mined in a similar
fashion
the bitcoin algorithm is programmed so
that the reward for mining new bitcoins
is halved every four years until the
year
2140 when all bitcoins will have been
deemed to have been
mined perhaps the mysterious creator
behind bitcoin
was trying to mimic the attributes of
gold almost as if to create a digital
gold coin
which could be divided and then sent
instantly around the world
i try to explain it in some really
simple way
like uh miners bitcoin iron miners
they receive the reward just because
they maintain security of bitcoin
mathematically
it means that you need to solve
quite difficult problems is that just
guessing process
you have to make millions and millions
millions of guesses
and if you're right and you're able to
close all these transactions inside of
one block
you're successful and you receive 12.5
bitcoins as minor
originally this reward was 50 bitcoins
every four years these
this reward for miners is two times
less so reward will be decreasing over
the time
the creator of bitcoin whoever he is was
a really really really smart guy
and uh he obviously liked math a lot and
he sat down and did some calculations
and thought to himself if everybody in
the entire world
were to start using bitcoin how many
bitcoins would we need in order for that
to be able to accommodate everybody
using bitcoin for this
and uh each bitcoin can be divided down
to 100 millionth of a bitcoin
and if everybody in the entire world
were to start using bitcoin
as their money the smallest unit of a
bitcoin which is called a satoshi it's
100 millionth of a bitcoin
would still be worth less than one us
penny if the entire world were to start
using bitcoin
so who is this satoshi nakamoto
two years after publishing the white
paper for the peer-to-peer
electronic cash system this mysterious
figure vanished
never to be heard from again the only
clues to his or her identity can be
found in the white paper
some speculate he or she is of british
origin
due to the writings containing some
british slang
others believe that rather than being
one person
satoshi was a group of hackers working
in concert
to create a new monetary system which
would decentralize money
as we know it i think he was a clever
guy he was not a normal geek
he had good knowledge of
decentralized technology or
decentralization
he had good knowledge financial system
and he was quite good coder
but the call the bitcoin is not
definitely the best one
so it's definitely possible to to write
better
code there is also conspiration theory
if bitcoin code
was written by one guy or many different
guys
hard to say anyway i
especially appreciate that it's
first fully working concept of the
centralized money
[Music]
it's very interesting like who satoshi
is
there's lots of speculation especially
among like the
very early people in bitcoin but what
difference does it make whether we know
who created bitcoin
uh i don't i don't know that it makes
any difference
there's lots of stuff that we use that
we don't know who created it
and yet it gives us a lot of advantages
in our day-to-day activities
i have no idea who satoshi is we know
very little about satoshi
and so he could be at an event he could
be someone we know could be someone i've
spoken to he could be a friend of mine
for all i know i don't know who it is
i don't know if we'll ever know but it's
a fun game
am i satoshi
[Music]
i don't think i'll answer that one
regardless of the true identity of
satoshi
what he or she has invented could have
profound effects
on how our world evolves into the future
because bitcoin enables the user to act
as their own bank in essence
it frees the user from the traditional
gatekeepers to their wealth
foreign
[Music]
we all use keys in our daily lives keys
allow us to access
and control our valued possessions they
also
protect our valuables from being stolen
take your car as an example holding the
keys to your car
allows you access to it whenever you
wish but suppose you've had a few too
many to drink
and your loyal friend confiscates your
keys from you
the car may still be yours but now you
no longer control it
and must hail a ride home the same can
be said of our finances
although you may have the debit card and
password to your bank account
the funds aren't directly in your
possession
every time you make a withdrawal or
transfer from your bank account
the bank is actually acting on your
behalf
and moving the funds for you this is
where bitcoin
is fundamentally different
bitcoin enables an individual to hold
the private keys
of their own wealth so with pretty much
every asset that we have out there
we don't directly hold the dominion or
control
over that asset for example
the royal bank of scotland they had 700
000
accounts atms just went down for the
weekend
nobody could access the atms couldn't
get money out
you have a credit card or a debit card
and it gets turned off because of
suspected fraud or you did a charge in a
unusual location guess what the credit
card company holds those private keys
they get to make the choice not you
bitcoin is very very different in this
regard
it is built on public private key
encryption
and what that means is that you send
bitcoins to the public key
and then in order to send the bitcoins
you have to be able to sign
with the private key where the bitcoins
uh currently reside and that literally
is a number that private key is a number
bitcoin nobody gets to turn it off if
you have the private key
you get to access it and use it
with your bitcoin wallets there's
associated um what are called private
keys
okay and these are literally what they
sound like they're private
keys that can open and unlock your
access to your funds
but let's be clear if you lose any of
your private keys you lose access to
your funds
simple as that
[Music]
so we just bought some bitcoins out of a
local bitcoin atm
and so what actually comes out is what
we call a cold wallet it's a little
piece of paper with
two squares on it or two things that
look like roche ink blotch tests
and a bunch of alphanumerics underneath
each now the top is the public
key which is what people would use to
send bitcoins to this address
and the bottom one is the private key
which is what you would use
to scan in order to retrieve bitcoins
from this address
now it's very important to note that
that private key is something that you
really shouldn't be
showing around everywhere because
whoever scans this first will be able to
take the bitcoins off this address
also if you were to happen to lose this
piece of paper then you've actually
essentially lost your bitcoins because
nobody else has a copy of this private
key
right now there actually is some
bitcoins on this address so if you're
seeing this for the first time you may
be able to scan this off yourself
and take the bitcoins for yourself
[Music]
so here is a satori coin there is a
value of
0.001 bitcoin inside
in today's exchange
rate that would mean about
45 cents so it's very minimal
amount but it is true bitcoin inside
now how to redeem the value out of this
token one would have to peel off
the hologram sticker in the back
here we go and then
our qr code would be exposed and this qr
code
is the private key information which is
essentially like
a password and with this
private key and only with this
private key one can redeem
you can import that value to your
bitcoin wallet
anything else physical has a very strong
sense of authority or authenticity
and to make the barrier to entry to
bitcoin as low as possible um
i think everyone working on their
project felt it was really important
that
someone could have a part of bitcoin
that they can hold in their hands that's
portable and uh doesn't cost very much
to get started
it's kind of a low commitment object
because bitcoin is built on public
private key encryption
the entire workflow for sending payments
particularly online
is fundamentally different from that of
credit cards
credit cards were never built to be used
on engine in the first place when the
credit cards were made
there was no internet so a pole system
is that
you've given the authorization to the
merchant or the credit card issue
to pull from your bank account whenever
it is that they feel that
they have the right to do so with a
credit card whenever you want to
initiate a transaction
you are effectively giving the keys to
the merchant
right and you give your keys to every
merchant you you deal with
um so every time you make a transaction
for example online or so you're taking a
risk because you're entrusting
the merchant with these this very
personal information which they could
then take
to initiate transactions as well if they
wanted to
whereas bitcoin is a completely
different model where the
control uh is
more weighted towards the the consumer
the consumer then pushes their funds to
you
um and then um if you're doing an
internet service right you could
broadcast
a bitcoin address and anyone in the
world could send bitcoin to you
if you were a band a musical band and
you're you're performing on a concert
and your concert was being broadcast uh
you know around the world
if you put up on the stage a you know
a sign that had a bitcoin address well
you could be funded by anyone who's
watching that broadcast anytime they
watched it
from that point onward
my name is sanshiro fujimoto and i play
the saxophone and the other instruments
i
compose and perform and make cds and i
make
my living by being a musician
today is a small live show i do
without no admission fee and
if you appreciate my music then
you can tip me
by tipping you don't know how much you
might get
zero or if your performance is great you
might
get more than you think so
that makes me play better
[Music]
[Applause]
direct interaction is more
more about the art itself
and if you tip someone in the street you
don't tip
big money you tip like 10 cents quarters
and
small money but to send the small money
on the internet costs
more than what you supposed to tip so
bitcoin is much better way to tip
someone in the internet
bitcoin payments are a push system
meaning that the funds are pushed from
sender to receiver
this makes for a faster and cheaper
system than traditional
pull systems like credit card
transactions
this in turn also means that bitcoin
transactions
are final and cannot be reversed
credit cards actually has about a six
month settlement time
even though the transaction looks like
it went through
the person can then call back and say
this was a fraudulent transaction
and then the credit card will take that
money away from the merchant in some
cases in some cases the credit card will
eat the cost
and that's a chargeback now we pay for
this this is the three percent
fee merchants usually pay this three
percent in order to accept credit cards
so bitcoin transactions don't have
chargebacks i think of it as a good
thing
um as much as people like to say how how
great it is to dispute things
it very very rarely happens almost never
do you order something from a legitimate
company
and you were not satisfied and then the
company did not solve your problem
most of the time this situation happens
is when your credit card is actually
stolen and your credit card is can
always be stolen
everyone's credit card is all over the
internet is just
luck or bad luck if your credit card
happens to be used in a fraudulent
transaction
we have some businesses accepting
bitcoin mostly restaurants for example
we have some restaurants here set up in
acapulco
for merchants when they accept bitcoin
is for them to have another option
an innovative option and for them they
have they have a lot of advantages we
don't charge what
the credit card fees charge every time
they slide the
the card three four five even ten
percent depending on the credit card we
don't charge anything
we don't have a minimum fee you can pay
10 pesos 50 pesos we don't have a
minimum
with bitcoin payments lowering the cost
of doing business
and eliminating the possibility of
fraudulent transactions
companies ranging from mom and pop
stores to multinational corporations
have started to embrace this new way to
transfer
value this is a
harvard medical school and this is
harvardshire
i visit this year it's 1997-1999
the first large publicly traded company
to accept bitcoin is overstock
and they now ship goods to over 200
countries
last i checked amazon only ships to
about 50
60 countries so they're seeding entire
markets
with entire populations in the billions
uh not even fighting for that market
share additionally if amazon accepted
bitcoin
there would be no fraud there would be
no chargebacks
so it would lower their costs it would
greatly increase
amazon's profit margins to accept
bitcoin
bitcoin allows merchants to accept
payments for their products and services
seamlessly and although it's becoming a
great tool
for merchants to offer their products to
previously untapped markets
it's the people in these developing
countries who will benefit the most
[Music]
bitcoin is the easiest safest fastest
best option for people
that don't have bank accounts or that
don't have ids or they don't have
anything but a smartphone and
there's lots and lots of people in the
world that that's the position
that they're in and bitcoin is this
fantastic solution and opportunity for
them to
participate in the world's economy
without having to to deal with banks and
having to jump through all these hoops
they just
simply install an app and now they're
part of the world's economy
something like 33 of the credit card
transactions coming out of
africa are fraudulent so nobody wants to
take
business from africa it's just too risky
with bitcoin you know the funds are good
so as a merchant
yeah pay with bitcoin also anything you
want you know that's legal to africa
then they're able to start having
property rights
and property rights is really what's
going to help
lift them up out of poverty
[Music]
so bitcoin does get into the this niche
of the
under service people in the banking
industry
so a lot of third world countries they
may not have access to bank accounts
they might not even have
ids to open a bank account but if they
have cell phones
and if they have access to the internet
they can now
have the equivalent of a bank in their
cell phone
according to the latest world bank
figures there are approximately two
billion
unbanked people throughout the
developing world
the adoption and use of bitcoin in these
countries
could transform this human rights issue
and allow the unbanked population of the
world
to participate in the global economy
for the first time in the entire history
of the world
anyone can now send or receive any
amount of money
with anyone else anywhere instantly
basically for free and it's impossible
for anyone
including governments to stop them from
doing that
and as much as i love gold gold gold
can't do that
right think about that
anybody in this room you can now sin and
receive any amount of money
with anyone anywhere in the world right
now and there's
nothing that anybody can do to stop that
that was not possible before the
invention of bitcoin and that is a
fundamentally
world-changing technology for every
single human being on the planet
wikileaks was able to find funding
through bitcoin
and this was in the midst of a financial
blockade that wikileaks was facing at
the time
the u.s had uh ordered the visa
i think was mastercard as well bank of
america to blockade any
donations to wikileaks say what you will
about wiki you know
wikileaks not necessarily that i condone
everything that
they do but i do think it is very
important um
for freedom in the world for people to
have uh uncensorable
ability to to donate money to whatever
political classes that they want to and
so
i thought that was extremely powerful
for
wikileaks to be able to defy the us in
that sense
because bitcoin puts the private keys of
wealth in the hands of the user
it can be used to support activist
causes
but bitcoin can also be used for a night
out on the town
my name is ken shishido i am
co-organizer for tokyo bitcoin meetup
group
we have this special event tonight
having burlesque dancers receiving
bitcoin tips
the reason why i do this is that
sometimes we want to
make our meetup interesting instead of
you know
talking about really really technical
stuff or political stuff
so this is one of the events we want to
make it really
fun and see what can be done using
[Music]
bitcoin
currently if you're living in in most
countries
buying things is not a problem you have
credit cards you can still use
cash and to me that is not
the true use of bitcoin the true use of
bitcoin is to give you financial privacy
which i find extremely important
during the global financial crisis as
cracks in the financial system spread
institutions once thought to be
invincible were shown to be vulnerable
as we now know governments around the
world were forced to bail out financial
institutions
a bailout is when government takes
taxpayer money
and gives it to an irresponsible
financial institution
to bail out their mistakes
a bail-in is different in that laws are
written which permit
financial institutions to take funds
directly from customer accounts
to shore up their losses
such a thing occurred in cyprus in 2013.
when i started learning about bitcoin
back in 2013 especially during the
cyprus event
when banks were shut down and money was
confiscated from people
i remember telling my co-workers some of
the phds the quants
this is really bad this is actually
going to probably start happening
in many other western countries and they
were all laughing at me saying no
it's just cyprus it'll never happen here
and that's when i knew someone must have
come up with
a way to get around this problem
when a depositor deposits dollars or
euros into the bank
title to the dollars or euros transfers
to the bank
and those depositors become unsecured
creditors
of the bank if the banks screw up for
whatever reason
there's now been legislation passed in
many of the countries where they can be
bailed in
meaning that their deposits can be
turned into shares
of the bank jeff berwick is an
entrepreneur
financial commentator and podcast host
having founded stockhouse.com canada's
largest financial news website
jeff's analysis writings and videos have
been viewed by millions of people
around the world it's difficult to say
exactly what's going to happen in the
future but
it's definitely going to keep happening
i said after cyprus is going to happen
in greece and then they shut down the
banks in greece for months
uh and re of interest to people who live
in europe is
on january 1st of this year they passed
a european bank bail-in legislation
so that that should be a huge wake-up
call to people that they're doing that
so
in cyprus they didn't actually pass it
before so in cyprus they closed the
banks
then they came up with some legislation
said the banks could just take their
customers money to keep afloat
so they didn't even have that
legislation and they did that in cyprus
now they already have it in place so
they know what's coming
i see bitcoin as a way to
protect and hide your assets and we're
not saying this is bad
i'm not saying that only criminals hide
their assets no
people that have worked hard and they've
paid taxes
and they've done everything and like
what happened in
greece and cyprus where money in bank
accounts was just confiscated
so if the next time the banking system
gets in trouble
it could be users accounts that are
rated to help
fund the banking system we're talking
people
with significant money a hundred
thousand
two hundred thousand but it's legal
money they've worked hard for it
some economists believe that the global
financial crisis of the last decade
was just a precursor to a much larger
calamity
if this is the case how will governments
react in response to the next
failure of our financial system
unlike the current banking system
bitcoin allows individuals to hold the
private keys to their wealth
however this also comes with the added
responsibility
of securing the bitcoins
with bitcoin you're in 100 percent
complete control of your own money
but that also means you're 100
responsible for what happens to your own
money so it's your job to make sure that
you keep your bitcoin
safe people are used to things like
credit cards and bank accounts and
paypal and if your credit card gets
stolen
you just call the credit card company
and they cancel it and that's the end of
it
if your bitcoins get stolen there's
nobody that you can call to ask to for
uh ask for help but uh the other side of
the coin there is there's nobody that
you have to call to ask for permission
to use your bitcoins however you want so
it cuts both ways
mount gox the tokyo based bitcoin
exchange has filed for bankruptcy
protection
the announcement comes days after the
exchange announced that as much as 450
million dollars of the virtual currency
had gone missing
ceo mark capelli's apologize and bowed
deeply on japanese television
it remains unclear if the missing
bitcoins were stolen
voided by technological flaws or both
so actually this is the the old mount
gox building
mount gox was the biggest bitcoin
exchange that ever existed i think at
some point they were doing over 100
million dollars a day worth of volume
and um they collapsed in a quite a
spectacular fashion
in 2014. i think the size of the losses
amounted to over 450 million dollars
they claim to have lost 850
000 bitcoins of which 200 000 were found
afterwards
in some old wallet people were putting
money in
and essentially giving them their
bitcoins giving them
the control of the private keys and and
the irony
is that exact centralization risk is
what bitcoin is supposed to
free us from and mount gox just took
all of the decentralized nature of
bitcoin and put it into one company with
a lot of people's money
and then on top of that put the control
of that company's finances
under one person who has the keys of the
kingdom
so we've probably seen over the last two
or three years i would
by my account probably somewhere between
half a dozen um
to upwards of 10 different major
hacks of companies that are involved in
bitcoin
and one thing you have to understand is
that bitcoin is fundamentally different
from
securing an asset that's you know that's
held within the regular financial space
uh with bitcoin if you ever get access
to the private key
of tucson's wallet you can initiate a
transaction
outside of the infrastructure of that
company without their knowledge
that's unlike anything that exists
currently in the financial space where
if you want to take money out of the
uh you know that target you have to have
infiltrated their
their infrastructure i think it's part
of the mentality where people are
trained
not to trust themselves with their own
money and so everybody puts their money
in bank for safekeeping
and so that that sort of mentality where
you put your money in
in some pooled company whose sole
purpose is to safeguard
it that is a really hard stigma to break
the change and i think this is the thing
that's the most challenging about
bitcoin is that
it challenges people to question that
stigma
it challenges people to take control of
your own
money and value and to safeguard it
yourself
as we know at this time bitcoin is quite
secure
if you have more than a half of
bitcoin natural power you can take a
control of the bitcoin network
but technically this is really hard
when we consider the current bitcoin
power
it's almost impossible so from this
point of view bitcoin is
much secure than the the biggest and
most secure
portals of some biggest banks in the
world
the problem is that many people do not
trust bitcoin
just because there were a lot of news
about hacking some bitcoin portals and
some exchange
services and so on the problem is that
uh
like all services uh
based on bitcoins is not a bitcoin you
know itself
so you can you cannot associate or
you cannot associate the security of
bitcoin-based services with the bitcoin
itself
the collapse of the mount gogs bitcoin
exchange in 2014
caused much confusion and skepticism
about the security of bitcoin
however years after the collapse of the
one's largest
bitcoin exchange bitcoin is now on the
radar of many institutions within the
financial industry
the big question that the conversation
you would you'd hear
is that the question was whether
blockchain technology
would impact the financial industry
and now if you go to the trade shows and
you listen to the media the question is
not whether the question is how
blockchain technology will will impact
and transform the financial industry
it's now a foregone conclusion that
blockchain technology will impact the
financial industry in a major way
so that's where we are now but we
weren't always there uh if you look
just three years ago two years ago
um the attitude was that bitcoin was
um almost a laughable concept and it was
a
non-sustainable system and it couldn't
be applied in the financial space
in japan the virtual currency law has
passed in the
lower house and hopefully actually it
will pass in the upper house as well in
the very near future
that means actually government
recognizes the existence of the virtual
currency
and then trying to actually set some
regressions
and trying to actually support the
business
[Music]
this bitcoin well it looks uh great
you know it's a
nice piece of collection you know better
than a
yen or a penny
some of the areas where bitcoin has been
most popular so far is china which has
quite a high level of capital controls
other countries like china argentina
iran this is where bitcoins really
caught on
to a lot of people because you just
simply it's not easy to transfer money
in or out of the country without going
through
regulatory problems or having to know
someone in the government and things
like that so
definitely that is a huge uh boost to
bitcoin
the advantages of bitcoin continue to
increase its popularity around the world
sometimes in the most unlikely of places
my name is david hyatt and i operate the
phoenix rising cafe in nimbun
this is where our bitcoin machine is
located
right next to the traditional atm
machine so the customers have a choice
of
using either i saw that the current
banking system was rather restrictive
and the independence of people running
their own
banking systems really appealed to me
and
the fact also that it was digital and
we're living in a digital age i just
knew that it was something that would
have to get traction over time
bitcoin is definitely the largest
innovation
in monetary science since isaac newton's
gold standard going to completely
revolutionize
how all of our assets are held so it's
going to disrupt the law
it's going to disrupt accounting going
to disrupt
our finance industry going to disrupt so
much
it will also rapidly decentralize
the capital no longer
will millions of people
accumulate all of their capital into one
big pile that then gets allocated by a
senior vice president of
merrill lynch or bank of america it'll
be millions of people that you have to
go
and entice out of their capital to go
fight a war in afghanistan
or iraq once you decentralize all those
private keys
becomes much more difficult to get
people to pay
for a lot of these goods and services
that they otherwise wouldn't necessarily
pay for
i'll just scan it and now i have your
bitcoin address in my wallet right here
and i'll go ahead and
enter one dollar and we'll hit send
mine's sending the transaction
[Music]
sent and if you there you go you heard
the noise
before bitcoin i was basically retired i
was just hanging out
enjoying my life practicing jiu jitsu
every day and it was really fun
but wasn't really going to make the
world that much of a better place
if at all and then i discovered bitcoin
and i looked around the world and i saw
these wars being fought
in central banks debased in the currency
and basically preventing the world from
being as good of a place as it
potentially could be
and i saw bitcoin and i saw this as a
tool to strip away
all of their power to do that most
people aren't interested in paying to
kill people they've never met in other
countries
most people are willing to pay for roads
and schools and hospitals
so if the government say we need money
for roads and schools and hospitals i
think people will probably give them
a good chunk of that if governments say
we need money to go kill people in other
countries that you've never been to in
your entire life
and you're probably never going to go to
in your entire life
people are going to say no i don't want
to pay for that but with if you're using
bank accounts and dollars and euros
governments can seize all the money out
of your bank account at any time they
can print as many new dollars or euros
as they want to pay for these things at
any time
if the world's using bitcoin it takes
away those tools from government and i
think that makes the world a much much
better place
for the first time in history bitcoin
now provides the entire world
with a completely decentralized payment
system
one where each individual holds the
ownership and control
of their own financial wealth
one where all users can transfer value
and
interact freely amongst each other
instantly
what could the future of our world look
like with such a revolutionary tool
the possibilities could be truly magical
[Music]
bitcoin is magic internet money uh
bitcoin allows you to send and receive
money with anyone anywhere in the world
just like magic there's
[Music]
i'm i'm at a loss for words because it's
that exciting and that world changing
with bitcoin you can pull out your ipod
or your iphone or your tablet or
whatever
install an app and in less than 30
seconds you have the ability to send and
receive money with anyone anywhere in
the world
basically for free and you can be 10
years old and do that
or you can be 100 years old and do that
you can do that in any country
that's magic
[Music]
you